the Russia Donald Trump story has grown
more wealth to say it's grown or we are
aware of how big it has gotten over the
last 24 hours it is not only the FBI but
there is an interagency group involving
six American agencies that are
investigating the Russian attempt to
influence the presidential election of
Donald Trump we are 24 hours before the
inauguration the knowledge that this
interagency group exists in and of
itself is huge but even bigger is that
this is a detailed investigation this
interagency group is looking not only
generally at Russian influence over the
American election of president-elect
Donald Trump but they are looking at the
money trail where and how whether and
how Russian money was covertly used to
help Donald Trump how would that money
have been moved etc the FBI the CIA the
NSA the Justice Department the Treasury
Department's Financial Crimes
enforcement Network and a representative
of the Director of National Intelligence
working together investigating
connections between the president-elect
who is hours from being sworn in and a
foreign entity called in 2012 by the
Republican nominee our greatest
geopolitical foe this is massive but but
but Pat what about Hillary Clinton's
emails and Benghazi yeah that's the
thing I think there's plenty of reasons
to give legitimacy to these claims
because many of these agencies have been
looking into these allegations since the
spring and summer certainly if they
found something conclusive to denounce
them they would have released that by
now this is not something as Pat is
alluding to that these agencies are just
starting to casually consider whether to
take a look at maybe investigators are
reportedly examining how the money may
have moved from the Kremlin to uses
meant to help Donald Trump win the
election and one of the allegations
involves whether a system for paying
thousands of russian-american pensioners
may have been used to pay some of the
email hackers in the United States or
maybe to supply money to intermediaries
who would then pay the hackers this is
all according the sources familiar with
the investigation even more interesting
is that this interagency group has been
working together since before the FBI
received the information about the
alleged Russian blackmail file we can
only assume I believe that since the
release since the acquiring of this
alleged Russian blackmail file that it
has ramped up this interagency
investigation I don't think people
realize how huge this is
Trump's transition team was asked for a
comment about this they didn't respond
this is McClatchy DC you can't write
this off as easily as fake news this
isn't fox or CNN or Rush Limbaugh or Jim
Acosta asking you a question at a press
conference which is not to deal with
Jinna my's Jim Acosta in any way this is
McClatchy DC they were all over the
Panama papers this is a serious news
organization at some point this is going
to explode right I mean the Trump lies
are slowly unraveling the suspicions are
slowly being confirmed this has got to
be a bomb waiting to go off and it's
really just a matter of horrible timing
because regardless Donald Trump is going
to be inaugurated tomorrow as the 45th
President of the United States yeah you
have to imagine that if it was so
important for understand the context of
Hillary email Hillary's email scandal
right during the campaign this story was
just as important oh yeah no there's a
total lack of urgency on this from the
trumpets get Hillary's emails out there
get two letters and one press conference
or two press conferences in one letter
from James Comey about the status of the
Hillary Clinton emails investigation Oh
Trump Russia connections dating back
months and months yeah it doesn't make
sense for us to hear about that the
inauguration is happening but it is
happening under the shadow of a
multi-agency investigation into how a
foreign power considered by the
president elects own party just months
ago to be our greatest geopolitical foe
how they helped to get him elected Trump
has had more scandals during the
transition period of the last two and a
half months than President Obama had
eight years and if you can shoot people
on Fifth Avenue Pat and nobody will care
clearly the trumpets in total denial
here about this I don't know what we
could tell them to get them to care
about this
yeah Trump has even had more scandals
than Lincoln Chaffey who if you remember
had no scandals throughout his whole
political career I will be sort of
paying attention to the inauguration
tomorrow we'll talk about that on
tomorrow's show but I am going to be
paying very very close attention to I
guess there's like what eight to ten
Trump related scandals currently going
on between pay to play
quid pro quo interagency investigation
into Russia cabinet corruption and
alleged insider trading sexual assault
allegations continue as we're going to
learn about today yes we're gonna talk
about that there's there's nearly a
dozen scandals right now around
president-elect Donald Trump and
tomorrow he will be speaking up if you
believe what his an aides say he'd wrote
the first draft of his speech he will be
speaking tomorrow as if everything is
just fine I'll talk more about his
speech a little later thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the David Pakman show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated